foreign
cards that we would possibly see open
from later position
who just stole one went away with 10-4
suited Ops not to try the same with the
5D is Suited
I'm uh spite has shown he likes Jack 10
off we'll try it again this time he's
the first to open rather than calling it
open like we had us done earlier
around two
are chess hero Magnus Carlson and the
big blind we will be defending
with the vessels
and Magnus Carlson improving the trips
on the Asus a spot we'll be checking
like he would be just a battery flop
despite checking back and now Spike has
a Broadway gut shot draw
that would be the only way to save him
Carlson checking again will swipe after
it's checked over twice to him
on the Flop Carlson we'll be checking
just about every flap rather than dunk
bedding
despite does indeed take a stab at it
and cross and Folds
and this may actually slow down the
action rather than speed it up because
fights did connect with that River
he did have Showdown value
and I think I'll check check on the
river and Carlson picks up a much needed
pot even though it wasn't large she's
back up to 73 000.
foreign